PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD AFTERNOON RESPONSE THE
COPA NINETY NUMBERS SEEM
PROTECT THE PUBLICLY JUST
LEADERS AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE TO SOCIAL DOESN'T SEEM
AN FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES OF ACCESS. TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING%
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODA EACH SIDE WILL
BE PERMITTED EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR AND TODAY THAT TIME HAS
BEEN. DETERMINED THAT LEE
WITNESSES WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH WITNESS. TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH AND THERE IS NO
RESERVING TIME FOR OTHER
WITNESSES ALL OTHER SWITCHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. FOR THESE.
WITNESSES THERE WILL BE A LIMIT
OF TEN MINUTES TOTAL FOR ALL
SUPPORT AND TEN MINUTES. TOTAL
FOR ALL IDENTIFIED OPPOSITION.
TWO OF THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS THE PUBLIC TO
TWO HEARING ROOMS THE EXTENT
THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS OVERALL AND WILL
BEUSING A TELECONFERENCE
ORDERS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE THREE. ONCE AGAIN.
THE NUMBER IS. 877-692-8953 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN OH
FIVE SIX NINE ONE NINE. SEVEN
FIVE SIX NINE OH NINE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TOKEN SYSTEM WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE IN OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION. PURPOSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU AWAY IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU
WILL BE. ON MUTE IN. AND AT
THAT TIME HE'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL CONTINUE I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY OF INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT. OUR
HEARINGS IN THIS CLOSE THE SAME
MANNERS IS CUSTOMARY THERE MAY
BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. CAN BE
HEARD. WE HAVE ONE BUILT ON
TODAY'S AGENDA SB SIX FORTY
SIX- BROUGHT FORWARD BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG BEFORE HERE HIS
PRESENTATION WITH STOPS A
QUORUM. CONSULTANT TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COURTESY. BUT AS
A YEAR OR TWO AGO. A TROUBLE
HERE TO WRESTLE THE RUSSELL
HERE LAYARD HERE LET HIM IN
HERE NEWMAN HERE. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. SENATOR
HERTZBERG IF YOU READY HERE YOU
MAY PROCEED TO PRESERVE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THIS TEAM
MEMBERS OF THIS VERY IMPORTANT
COMMITTEES CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE. IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY ONE OF OUR TEN
CAMPUSES SHOULD REPORT. RACE TO
THE BOTTOM RACE TO THE BOTTOM
WHAT HAVE WE BEEN TRYING TO DO
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF DECADES
IN THIS LEGISLATURE IN TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW WE
WE'VE DONE THIS FOR A CENTURY
BASICALLY BUT AS WE DIG DEEPER
WE FIND INSTANCES WHERE CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES ARE PARTICULARLY
IMPACTED JANITORIAL BUSINESS IS
ONE OF THOSE AREAS. OF WORK
WHERE IT WORKERS ARE OFTEN
EXPLOITED AND DON'T RECEIVE THE
LEVEL OF PROTECTIONS TO SERIOUS
CONTRACTING AND HIRING
PROCESSES SO WHAT ARE WE TRYING
TO DO IN THIS BILL WHY HAVE WE
INTRODUCE IT NOW WHY YOU TAKING
TIME AWAY FROM SESSION TO HEAR
THIS. BECAUSE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY WITH SOME COMPANIES
TO BE ABLE TO CHANGE THE LAW IN
THE WAY. THAT INCENTIVIZES
ORGANIZED LABOR THROUGH VARIOUS
EXEMPTIONS OF PAGA AND THE LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO THESE EMPLOYERS.
TO ORGANIZED HELPS THE
EMPLOYERS ON THE ONE HAND AND
HELPS THE WORKERS ON THE OTHER
IT IS A UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCE WE
DON'T DO THIS IN ALL DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE LAW. YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A SHOWING AND THE REASON I
STARTED WITH THE NOTION ABOUT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA'S
RACE TO THE BOTTOM. IS IT
INFORMS THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
THESE FOLKS. THAT ARE THE
JANITORIAL BUSINESS THAT ARE
BEING EXPLOITED. AND THAT'S THE
REASON I'M HERE TODAY THAT'S
THE REASON WHY WE INTRODUCED
THIS LEGISLATION AND THAT'S THE
REASON WHY I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT DESERVES
THE ATTENTION OF THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATURE WITH THAT- WE HAVE
DEAN. THE FELLOW AND BEHALF OF
ABM INDUSTRIES. IS THAT THE
COMPANY THAT WHAT'S HIS IMAGE
THAT WHAT'S HIS NAME STARTED
TO. THE COMMISSION SCHOOL OF
THE I CAN REMEMBER HE STARTED A
COMPANY. BUT WHATEVER SO ON
BEHALF OF ABM INDUSTRIES.
PLEASE THANK YOU. I THINK THE
SOONER- LEAD SPORT WITNESSES
TEAMS GROW PHIL- YOU MAY COME
FORWARD IN THE BEGIN YOUR
TESTIMONY AS WE INDICATED-
THERE'S BEEN A OF. A LIMITATION
OR CONSTRAINT ON. LEAD AND LEAD
TESTIMONY IN GENERAL SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF TWO MINUTES IF
YOU COULD TRY TO ABIDE BY THAT
WOULD. APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU MAY PROCEED.
SENATORS IS MEANT MY NAME IS
DEAN OF ON BEHALF OF. ABM
INDUSTRIES INCORPORATED SPONSOR
FOR SB SIX FORTY SIX. THANK YOU
SENATOR STEINBERG FOR OFFERING
THIS BILL I DO NOT I DO NOT
HAVE HERTZBERG WORLD THE SAME
KIND OF. SORRY SORRY HERTZBERG
SIZE SIX OKAY GUYS I LOVE
STEINBERG TO BE A- IS A MUCH
BETTER TENNIS PLAYER. NO I DO
NOT HAVE MUCH MORE TO ADD TO
WHAT YOU ALREADY STATED MISTER
HERTZBERG. FUNDAMENTALLY SB SIX
FOUR SIX WE HOPE TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF WHAT WAS MUTUALLY
AGREED UPON VIA THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS A VALUE THIS
COMMITTEE HAD HOUSES FOLLOWED
REPEATEDLY. SIMILAR TO WHAT
THIS COMMITTEE PASSED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH AB SIXTEEN FIFTY
FOUR BUT IN AN EVEN MORE NARROW
WAY. SB SIX FORTY SIX WILL
ALLOW THE CBA TO BE FULLY
REALIZED. THIS BILL WILL ONLY
IMPACT APPROXIMATELY 11% OF
JANITORS IN CALIFORNIA. TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
PREDOMINATELY LATINO IMMIGRANTS
FLY BY NIGHT JANITORIAL
CONTRACTORS TO OFTEN MAKE A
FAST BUCK FAST BUCK OFF THE
BACK OF THESE INDIVIDUALS.
THREATENING THE STABLE AND
STRONG WAGES AND BENEFITS WE
PROVIDE AS WE CONTINUE TO
STRIVE TO BE A GOOD CORPORATE
CITIZEN. BY VOTING IN FAVOR FOR
SB SIX FORTY SIX YOUR VOTE WILL
HELP ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
SCOFFLAW SUBCONTRACTORS THAT
USE OTHER CROOKS THAT SKIRT THE
LAW HAS ARTICULATED IT IN UC
BERKELEY'S REPORT. AS WEAK AS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT YOUR RIVAL
WILL HELP STRENGTHEN OUR CBA'S
AND DECADES LONG RELATIONSHIP.
WE'VE HAD WITH A C. ARE YOU.
THIS BILL HAS REACHED STRONG
BIASES BY CAR SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. PLEASE VOTE AYE ON SB
SIX FORTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY BUT
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NO TO A
GENERAL SUPPORT TESTIMONY OF
THOSE. WHO ARE WISHING TO
INDICATE SUPPORT EMAIL- DO SO
BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE A PROMISE
TO NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE MEASURE WHICH
AT THIS POINT WOULD BE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS RENEE BY
OUR WITH S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN ROOM FOR
TWO OR THREE THAT WISHES TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT- SEEN NONE WILL
CHECK THE OVERFLOW ROOM- FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY SEEN
NONE THERE WILL GO TO THE
MODERATOR NOW. AND S. MODERATOR
TO QUEUE UP ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY OVER THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOUR SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT SB SIX FORTY
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
GENERAL. WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. I THINK YOU MOTOR
MODERATOR ROOM WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS NOW TO
ABOUT EQUAL TIME FOR OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO WE DON'T POSITION
WITNESS IDENTIFIED SO ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM FOR TWO OR THREE
WISHES TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL SO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. THE SCENE KNOWN COME
FORWARD WILL CHECK THE OVERFLOW
ROOM. UNDER PEERS BE NO WHEN
THEY'RE WISHING TO TESTIFY AND
WE'LL GO BACK TO MODERNISE
MODERATOR- TO PLEASE CHECK THE
QUEUE OF FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION. TO THIS
BILL AT THIS TIME. AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
FORTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FORTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU FOR
CHECKING MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
COME BACK NOW TO THE COMMITTEE
AND ASK IF THERE'S ARE ANY.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR GENERAL
DISCUSSION FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR ALSO I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL BUT- ALSO
COMMENT THAT I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS. INTRODUCE IN THIS- TO
ME IT'S ALWAYS BEEN MUCH BETTER
WHEN THERE'S COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THE TAKES
CARE. AND ADDRESSES THE ISSUES
OF WAGES AND- IF SOMEBODY
DOESN'T FOLLOW THE WAGES YOU
KNOW THERE'S A WHOLE PROCESS
INTERNAL PROCESS THERE SO- I
BELIEVE IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING A LOT MORE THAN JUST
FOLLOWING A LOT OF LAWSUITS- SO
I APPRECIATE THAT. THAT'S BEEN
DONE HERE THANK. CRITICS UNDER
ANY ANYBODY ELSE ANYTHING ELSE
NO ONE ELSE WISHING TO BE
RECOGNISED SENT YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE SENATORS FOR
YEAH JUST VERY QUICKLY WHEN
CENTER DONE INTRODUCED THE BILL
PASSED THE PAGA BILL. I CAN
REMEMBER THAT WAS WHEN I WAS
AROUND IN THOSE DAYS THE
PURPOSE WAS WHERE. PLEASE SIR
IN SITUATION LIKE THIS DIDN'T
HAVE THE BENEFITS OF THE
COLLECTIVE OF A UNION TO
REPRESENT THEM. THE WHOLE
THEORY BEHIND LABOR LAW IS THAT
WE AS A STATE PROTECT THE
INDIVIDUAL. UNLESS OF COURSE
THE INDIVIDUAL COOK WHO JOINS
TOGETHER AND HAS A SUFFICIENT
BARGAINING POWER TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. AND SO THIS
COMPROMISE THAT'S HERE D.
DRESSES WITH THIS RACE TO THE
BOTTOM ISSUE ON THE ONE HAND.
AND REALLY IN THIS UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN A COMPROMISE
AT ALL. BECAUSE THESE THESE
THINGS CAN BE A PER DAY POLICE
CAN BE PROTECTED- RATHER THAN
BEING ACTING ON THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL BEHALF AND SO WITH
THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CENTER STEINBERG I
MEAN HERTZBERG. OKAY IF YOU'RE
REALLY OLD HE OF THE HEISENBERG-
WE ARE GOING TO COME BACK TO
THE MOTION BY SENATOR TO
RUSSELL IN ASKING SOLUM TO CALL
THE ROLL CALL PLEASE. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN.
COURTESY HI WHERE DOES THE I
HAVE A TROUBLED. A TROUBLED NOW.
WRESTLE RUSSELL I LAYERED HI
THERE I NEWMAN. NEWMAN AYE.
THREE THE BILL WAS OUT ON A
FOUR TO ONE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MAN BEFORE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR ALL
JOKING ASIDE WHO GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK- BEFORE WE ADJOURN
LET ME JUST MAKE A VERY QUICKLY
KNOWLEDGE MINUTE THE COMBI HALF
OF ALL OF US- TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF HERE YOU KNOW I DIDN'T DO
THIS AT OUR LST MEETING
BECAUSE SOMETHING TOLD ME THERE
WAS A LIKELIHOOD WE MIGHT BE
BACK. TOGETHER BEFORE THE END
OF THE SESSION- OMA PRESS GOING
MILES IN CHECK FOR ARE YOU
THINK DONE A LOT OF WORK WITH
ALL OF US YOU KNOW HELPING
PREPARE ALL OF US- I WILL
EXERCISE A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE AND THANK- MY
CHEAPEST OF SUNSHINE GRILLI WHO
TAKES IT UPON HERSELF TO STUFF-
THIS PARTICULAR COMMITTEE IN
THIS PARTICULAR SUBJECT AREA
UT TO ALMOST PARTICULARLY WHO-
JUST YOU KNOW. JUST A FEW
WEEKS- IF THAT INTO THE SESSION
WAS WAS NAMED THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT FOR THIS COMMITTEE
AND YOU KNOW I WAS REALLY KIND
OF BUSY AND REMISS IN MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT TOO NEW TO- TO PAUSE
FOR A MINUTE AND CONGRATULATE
YOU AT THAT TIME AND JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THAT
HERE BEFORE THE SESSION WRAPS
UP SO A LITTLE BELATED
CONGRATULATIONS YOU'RE ROLLED
AND THANK YOU AND TO THE CART
STUFF IN THE CONSULTANTS FOR
JUST DOING A TERRIFIC JOB ALL
YEAR LONG THANK YOU MAYBE WE
CAN. ENGAGE IN A. THE LITTLE
ROUND WILL COST. WITHOUT WE NO
A JURY